why don't you all introduce yourselves
so who have we got here
hello we are
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ruk it's a bloody beautiful night
[Applause]
Tongo Wow I meant in economy me yep
[Applause]
hello my name is Ian I'm worldwide the
handsome you know
[Applause]
that's mr. guy I see six members but
they're supposed to be seven what
happened
there's a demon called remember well Jim
Jim in yesugai's seized up before the
rehearsal so I know but you can't be Jim
in today so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry we don't we don't need today and
that who's hurt their foot then who was
that young cook jungle stitches yeah so
many people would like to kiss it better
[Applause]
we should you should say that song idol
that is on the album love yourself
answer which is out now yes thing
they've already got its but so I suppose
the the headline so the headlines are so
BTS stands for BTS is be on the scene in
English that Boy Scout in Korea okay
yeah okay so that's what that is yeah
I'm no wiser as the behind it scene but
which is not you know and I don't mean
any disrespect there are people of a
certain age who don't know BTS so just
in case you are thinking I'm making this
up this is the new cover of Time
magazine
[Applause]
yeah anyone know the cover No so and you
also you had the honor of speaking at
the United Nations that was not a part
of bts's message oh yeah yeah okay so I
just want to say that you know life
always had two dilemmas of you know we
always have to have the pain inside
because when the light comes we always
have the shadows we cannot be avoid from
that so I just want to tell that um we
should find the way to lower ourselves
around then of course especially the
youth gonna be more happy and we could
live a good life so that was the message
[Applause]
[Music]
giving them my shirt
it's
[Applause]
[Music]
dressing a big ol book and I'm giving
you this to say thank you for you to
love me like you all of the joy you're
bringing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
and if you look closely it's all about
movement and people it's all for is for
you
[Applause]
[Music]